so let's get right to it show me what
you've built and why people are losing
their minds over it let's go what the AI
is doing is is getting this initial
image that we have on the left side and
it's turning it into something that
looks very much realistic on the right
what is new is that if I start moving
this ping Circle you will see that the
Frog starts moving around in real time
this is right now giving me full control
it's giving me a whole new dimension uh
for prompting let's do a
bluebird on top of it a blue mushroom if
I change the color here so you're
changing the color palette and then AI
is automatically reacting to that
exactly the input image is on on the
left side and it's kind of autoc comp
completing it with this final result
that looks very
realistic